[Musique]
ils étaient entre son 1000 et 170 mille
manifestants selon les sources à
descendre dans la rue hier
paris trente quatre personnes ont été
interpellées selon la préfecture
ailleurs en france à lyon c'est un
policier qui a été attaqué dans le doubs
donc on voit qu'il ya une forme de
radicalité dans l'action et de grande
violence dans l'action y compris en
direction des organisateurs eux-mêmes
alors que le cortège syndical arrive à
la fin du parcours il est prise à partie
par des gilet jaune et des individus
cagoulés des bagarres éclatent
puis les insultes fusent on est
scandalisé par par par de tels faits
c'était avait un véritable guet-apens
qu'on a tendu à mes camarades les
véhicules tente de s'enfuir mais ils
sont piégés entre les barrages des crs
et la foule toujours plus hostile le
premier ministre confiant qu'il y aura
une alliance en paca pour les régionales
les listes
lrm et élèves vont fusionner au profit
d'une liste commune
emmenés par le sortant le républicain
renaud muselier vous avez aujourd'hui
chez les élèves ceux qui veulent
construire avec nous ceux qui veulent
participative et avec le rassemblement
national eric ciotti je vous le citez à
l'instant qui dit qu'il n'y a plus de
différence de ligne de fond avec le
rassemblement national ce qui est une
vraie rupture
regardez ce qui se passe en région
bourgogne franche comté vous avez le
candidat ait l'air gilles platret qui
fait un accord avec des anciens cadres
du rassemblement national avec le parti
de nicolas dupont aignan gilles platret
est un homme lit maire de chalon qu'a
pris des positions très audacieuse en
refus des communautarismes refus de
l'immigration
c'est un gaulliste de coeur qui refuse
totalement la dérive des dirigeants
aient l'air vers en marche et je
refuserais eu l'accord la main tendue
qu'il m'a fait
l'ailer le parti c'est devenu une façade
c'est un décor de cinéma
c'est des voyageurs le boutiquier d'état
major au détriment des habitants donc la
seule liste d'opposition face à ce
système
eh bien ça sera la liste menée par
thierry mariani ça peut faire fuir un
certain nombre d'électeurs des
républicains qui ne peuvent pas
comprendre
que l'on critique matin midi et manuel
macron quant à sa politique nationale
voire quant à ses répercussions au plan
local et qu'ensuite pour essayer de se
sauver sa vie à emmanuel macron renaud
muselier ne représente plus sa famille
politique du moins officiellement
le président du parti christian jacob
lui retire l'investiture l air dans un
communiqué publié en fin de matinée et
je le dis à renaud muselier
il fait une erreur une terrible erreur
parce que seul il peut gagner avec en
marche il ne gagnera pas et il faut
rassembler autour de ce projet mais sans
faire d'alliance avec des partis
politiques qui ne sont pas feints qui
vont politisé l'élection alors qu'il
faut au contraire la régionaliser rave
party organisée dans le xiième parc de
bercy à paris près entre 200 et 300
fêtards s'y étaient donné rendez vous
musique à fond tout le matériel sono a
été a été saisi et dans le même temps
une autre fête était dispersé hier à
bruxelles en belgique
un millier de personnes participaient à
un rassemblement dans un parc de la
capitale
et les gens qui viennent dire voyez
l'état nous impose l'état et liberticide
mais la liberté c'est court l'occurrence
la liberté de contaminer les autres
autre rêve party 500 teufeurs ont
participé donc à cette fête organisée
dans un entrepôt à 5h30 ce matin la fête
battait encore son plein selon le maire
à chaque fois l'organisateur est le même
un collectif nommé là bim qui indique
clairement les choses sur son site
internet
cette fête sera donc aussi un mouvement
citoyen de désobéissance civile qui
dansera pour récupérer son droit à se
réunir
qu'est ce que vous dites aux teufeurs
ont dit qu'ils feraient mieux de rester
chez eux qu'ils patientent encore un peu